okay in this problem a 45° vnch Weir has
an upstream depth of 5 in above the
crest of the Weir find the flow and
CFS so there's not a lot of information
in this problem which is good for us
because that means there's not a lot
we're going to have to solve for
probably um the first thing I would do
is look up vnch Weirs and if we do that
in the reference manual you'll see that
it does take take you to an equation on
page
320 given as follows so Q
equal 8 over
CD * the square < TK of
2G time tangent of theta /
2 time the height raised to the 5/
2 so in this case we've got Theta as the
VN angle in degrees H is the head or
depth of discharge over the Weir CD is
your coefficient of
discharge so let's start filling in some
of these terms just to simplify the
equation so first we could just solve
for tangent of theta / 2 and because
this is a 45° V Notch Weir it's going to
be tangent of 45 over 2 this should give
us an answer of about
0.414 make sure you're in degrees on
your
calculator not
radians okay
next coefficient of
discharge so we can look at the graph on
the next page of the manual on
321 so this is going to be in
section c graph
at 6.
2.5.6 so this graph has a series of
Curves on it and if we follow along the
curve for the 45° vnch Weir until we get
to the height
of 5 in however the height on the graph
is ft
so 5 in over 12 in gives us just
about
416 ft so if we go just a little bit
past
0.4 we can see that the CD value is
going to be pretty close
to
0.605 at at
45° at y = 5 in/ 12 in just writing this
again equals 016
ft okay so now all we have to do is
solve the problem so Q
= 8 over 15 *
0.605 * 2 * 3
2.2 ft/s
squared times we said tangent of theta /
2 =
0.414 and H is going to be
0.416 raised to the 5 over
2 and that's
feet so we can see here that actually
fet to 5/ 2
* the square root ofet over seconds
after this gets simplified will give us
cubic feet per second which is just good
to double check and if we solve this out
we can see that Q equals just about
0.12 cubic feet per
second and our closest Value here is
going to be
0.11 if you don't get the exact same
answer that's fine as long as you're
close and that's going to be because of
probably what you select for CD on the
graph and how many units of precision
you might use when calculating
for your tangent value here again just
make sure that you're using degrees and
not radians for this
question um that's about it for this
problem if you
can use your context clues to go find
the equation you need for the vnch Weir
and determine that how to solve for each
of the other unknowns so pretty much
really just C
um that's that's going to be all it
takes to solve this
problem